what's going on guys
there is yet another new Marvel trailer
upon us Ant Man are we excited about it
what is Ant Man what's going on with it
we have an awesome panel to break it
down with us today first he's a friend
of the show he's been with us many times
actor comedian Mike Carlson thank you
for having me he'll always a pleasure
and he is a former writer for Marvel
Comics having written the Ultimates and
he's a current writer of several indie
comics including the bunker and life
after let's welcome Josh V Alka I was
beautiful thank you so much for having
me what did you guys think of the
trailer overall I'm look I'm I'm
tentative but at the same time you know
I think the fact that Edgar Wright was
on the movie until so close to when I
started shooting kind of gave everybody
the heebie-jeebies when they kicked him
out the door oh sure um but that being
said Marvel has made very few missteps
and I think they know what important it
is to keep these movies alive they
certainly are working yeah they
certainly earned the benefit of the
doubt at this point the number one thing
I noticed is that any time Michael
Douglas says the name Scott I think of
Liberace and behind the candelabra
an etruscan
I need you say yes God as a fan of the
comics were there any nuggets in there
that got you super pumped Joey oh yeah
well my favorite nugget was when he gets
on top of that ant and he's running an
ant around because that's that's great I
want so much of that and the way that
the way that you actually when you see
the shrinking powers it was like one
really great shot of him shrinking and
we sort of stay in proportion to him I
think it's awesome it's really really
cool and you're like okay this is gonna
work like it's not gonna feel ridiculous
how different is ant-man from Honey I
Shrunk the Kids
mmm it's the same exact same gotcha if
you leave here with one thing today know
that ant-man is exactly the same as
Honey I Shrunk the Kids let's break down
what we saw a little bit in this trailer
Paul Rudd got out of jail Michael
Douglas was giving him kind of the
generic superhero you're gonna have
great power and stuff kind of talk Paul
Rudd plays Scott Lang who is ant-man
there are many different ant-man in the
Marvel Universe there's Scott Lang Hank
Pym there's also a guy named Erik
O'Grady who I don't think is in this
movie and it's all pretty close to the
comics like that part's actually pretty
spot-on Hank Pym is a foundational
character for the Marvel Universe he was
actually created by Stan Lee and Larry
Lieber and Jack Kirby and he was one of
the original Avengers when Scott Lang
became ant-man he had just gotten out of
jail and his daughter was sick and the
only way he could get the medicine to
treat his daughter was to steal the
ant-man costume which then inspires Hank
Pym to allow him to continue to wear it
which is a very 70s marvel at like
stories Paul Rudd is a pretty great
choice for that because he is the kind
of guy he could be a criminal but he's
still charming and abs he's got abs now
so here's Paul Rudd is also in the
trailer was Corey Stoll who I love from
house of cards can you tell me a little
bit about his character he's playing
Darren cross who became a character
called yellow jacket i mean yellow
jacket is sort of like the bizarro
version of vamp man so he has similar
powers he's got the technology yeah he
has the same exactly is the same
technology in the comics he serves as
sort of like the anger that's inside
hank pym and inside Scott Lang like he
serves as sort of a counterpoint to it
can you break down a little bit what are
the what are the ant-man powers he can
shrink down his strength increases as he
shrinks yeah
he can ride on insects specifically ants
honking mind he actually can
mind-control ants so he can build his
own little army that's at any size
whether he's little herb is he ever ruin
a picnic trust me if you read the comics
that guy ruined a lot of picnics that's
what I saw one of the things about the
comic and I think there's a lot of
people who are irritated that it's not
about Hank Pym
yeah because Hank Pym there's a there's
a bunch of storylines that he's really
important to first of all is he in the
comics is one of the founding Avengers
he created Ultron yeah it was going to
be the villain in Avengers 2 he
eventually had a split personality at
one point and in fact it became
yellowjacket and he he's this very like
kind of deep and textured character but
now the question becomes and for
everybody who has read the comics you
start wondering well how much of that is
actually going to come in is Michael
Douglas actually a good guy is he not
actually the bad guy oh so you're saying
he can go all Jeff Bridges on us yes yes
possibly Evangeline Lilly making a brief
appearance in the trailer
she plays hope Van Dyne which is the
daughter of Janet Van Dyne right so um
can we expect Evangeline Lilly to be
playing wasp I mean one would hope
probably we would hope here's another
thing I'm wondering this seems to be a
standalone film but Marvel is opening up
the universe with Civil War and the
infinity wars are coming up so how do we
see ant-man fitting into the big picture
well I think that the movie will fit
into the Marvel Universe just because
Hank Pym is obviously a guy that seems
like he's been ant-man before he's had
this technology for a while so they're
gonna probably put in some things like
where he's been superheroing now for the
last you know 3040 years in the comics
Hawkeye has actually very similar origin
where Hawkeye was a criminal who got
reformed so I think having this
character who has you know has the rest
of the Avengers to kind of look up to
and try to find his place with them I
think it's really cool and I think
there's a lot of there's a lot of rope
there you know there's a lot of room for
them to do something let's just hope
there's not enough rope for them to hang
them so let me ask you this people
weren't exactly going crazy for ant-man
right now but they weren't exactly going
crazy they don't know what to expect
with guardians now we see what guardians
have has become could this thing blow up
like guardians I mean it has the
potential to just because it's Marvel I
mean look the whole point of guardians
to some degree was to see like okay
these characters have literally no name
recognition
whatsoever mm-hmm can we do it ant-man
has almost the next step of that which
is like this one has a ridiculous name
that nobody's gonna be into what can we
do it's a tuna to change the name with
ant-man they're probably worried to some
degree about making sure that like no no
this has steaks and what happens and it
matters which Guardians gets almost by
default because it's about the universe
like it's they're protecting I don't
know if you know this the galaxy mm-hmm
so you know like you get this sense of
scope with that what you don't
necessarily have an ant-man so I think
they're probably fighting a bit amongst
the tone like how do we present it so
that people feel like this movie is
important and essential to the whole
thing while still you know dealing with
who we have in the script we have in the
comedic potential of it okay doomsday
scenario what if ant-man
bombs unthinkable in this Marvel climate
if that happens what are the chances
that ant-man just slinks away to his
anthill and is never to be heard from
again
like I think they'll bench ant-man for a
little bit like maybe there'll be some
sort of a nod and infinity war it's like
he's homeless or something with a cup or
some but he'll be an ant-man like in
2025 we'll get a revamped ant-man it
just might be a longer time if this
movie doesn't do as well what did you
think about the ant-man trailer are you
excited for the movie let us know in the
comments section below the coolest
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank my
esteemed panel Mike Carlson thanks for
being here again and Josh be al-kahf a
pleasure having you sir thank you so
much hey if you're watching this show
you're probably a fan of movies guess
what you're in luck now you can watch
free full-length movies online via
movies on break we have a ton of movie
categories for you to choose from
including screen junkies approved to
start watching free full-length movies
right now go to break comm slash movies
or check it out on any of breaks free
mobile apps what are you waiting for you
filthy animal
thank you for watching I'm howling it
kept me up on Twitter bye bye
this is the movie that got leaked online
so he wasn't gonna make it and now he is
it's a revenge Weston I love Django
Unchained inside-out the next Pixar
movie and the other one I think people
are talking about yet is tomorrow which
is Brad Birds movie written co-written
by Damon Lindelof George Clooney and
it's about this alternate dimension was
a futuristic thing that the trailer was
really good really good tease yeah
really striking teaser